die negativ schlagzeilen rund um
verbrennungsmotoren reißen einfach nicht
ab ist jetzt vielleicht endlich die
stunde der elektroautos gekommen also
für die elektrische revolution die
absatzzahlen der e autos sprechen eine
andere sprache zu hoch ist der preis zu
kurz die reichweite und zu umständlich
der ladevorgang noch denn in den
nächsten jahren werden
technologiesprünge erwartet die unsere
skepsis gegenüber e autos in
begeisterung umschlagen lassen könnten
mehr darüber jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen nach
frankreich zieht jetzt auch
großbritannien nach unsere französischen
nachbarn wollen den verkauf von
verbrennungsmotoren bis 2040 komplett
einstellen auf britischen straßen sollen
dann nur noch elektroautos zugelassen
werden in deutschland ist ein solcher
plan noch zukunftsmusik und auf
deutschen straßen kommen elektroautos
auch nicht so wirklich ins rollen woran
es liegt die große skepsis der deutschen
wenn es um elektroautos geht an der
auswahl der elektrofahrzeuge kann es
inzwischen nicht mehr liegen 100
einträge zählt die liste des bundesamts
für wirtschaft und ausfuhrkontrolle
sie reicht von a wie audi bis vw volvo
und zählt die verschiedenen typen von
elektrofahrzeugen auf die sich deutsche
autokäufer derzeit mit der sogenannten
elektroauto prämie bezuschussen lassen
können doch auch wenn das angebot groß
ist die absatzzahlen der e-autos sind
kaum erwähnenswert 2016 kam voll
elektrische wagen mit batterie zusammen
mit teil elektrischen hybriden deren
elektromotor an der steckdose aufgeladen
werden muss gerade einmal auf einen
marktanteil achtung von 0,7 prozent
dagegen wurden gut drei millionen neue
fahrzeuge mit gewöhnlichen
verbrennungsmotoren verkauft einen
anteil von rund 98 prozent in
verschiedenen befragungen geben wir
deutschen an dass uns vor allem der
kaufpreis abschreckt auch eine zu
geringe reichweite und eine schlechte
infrastruktur was die lademöglichkeiten
der e autos angeht hält die befragten
davon ab den kauf eines e autos
überhaupt in betracht zu ziehen das
alles sind aspekte die bei einer
kaufentscheidung einfach überwiegen und
zwar zurecht und das obwohl so viele
deutsche in ihrem sonstigen alltag
umweltbewusst und grün handel
doch experten sagen rasante entwicklung
für die kommenden jahrzehnte voraus die
opec sagt für das jahr 2040 und 266
millionen stromer auf den straßen voraus
plugin autos also rein und teil
elektrische fahrzeuge mit extern
aufladbaren batterie sondern dann ein
drittel des weltweiten bestandes
ausmachen ihre prognosen für die zu
erwartende zahl der diesel fahrzeuge im
jahr 2040 haben die wirtschaftsexperten
stattdessen halbiert die vorhersagen
dieses aufwärtstrends basieren auf
technologischen innovationen in diesem
bereich kombiniert mit sinkenden preisen
jetzt schon werden die batterien immer
effizienter und elektroautos wie der
opel ampera kommt mit einer ladung
bereits knapp 400 kilometer weit
doch es gibt weitere technologiesprünge
beispiel ladung das kalifornische
unternehmen cor kommen will das
induktive aufladen populär machen lade
platten auf dem supermarkt platz vor der
ampel oder verbaut in die autobahn in
der zukunft bräuchte er auto so keine
riesigen batterien mehr um genügend
reichweite für den nachhauseweg zu haben
dadurch könnten sie deutlich
kostengünstiger werden schon im
kommenden jahr sollen die ersten
fahrzeuge auf den markt kommen die sich
dann ähnlich wie eine elektrische
zahnbürste induktiv aufladen lassen
können ein großes hindernis für die
elektromobilität wäre so beseitigt
reichweite wäre kein thema mehr und auch
die großen traditionellen autobauer
selbst investieren weiter in diese
branche technologiesprung bei toyota
hier wird zurzeit eine batterie mit
einer deutlich kürzeren aufladezeit
entwickelt und selbst im motorsport weht
plötzlich ein anderer wind mercedes will
nun aus der deutschen
tourenwagen-meisterschaft aussteigen und
stattdessen ab der saison 2009 10 20 in
der formel durchstarten
doch damit sie elektroautos wirklich auf
den deutschen straßen durchsetzen können
braucht es noch viel mehr als
technologiesprünge kleinere preise und
eine gute infrastruktur die politische
unterstützung ja und schaut man mal in
andere länder die in sachen
elektromobilität ganz weit oben sind
wird eine sache klar überall dort werden
autos vom staat enorm gefördert
das ziel der deutschen bundesregierung
bis 2020 eine million elektroautos auf
die
so bringen aber damit werden die
politiker aller voraussicht nach
kläglich scheitern wenn man die
aktuellen zulassungszahlen sieht und das
wird nämlich ziemlich peinlich 2011
wurde dieses ziel festgeschrieben es ist
aber das papier nicht wert auf dem es
steht wirklich bemüht hat sich niemand
das ziel wirklich zu erreichen wenn
jetzt darüber geklagt wird dass die
chinesen zum weltmarktführer für
elektroautos geworden sind und die
deutschen meilen hinterher hinken
dann soll sich die politik mal an die
eigene nase packen sie hat es verbockt
es benötigt dann innovative unternehmen
wie die streetscooter gmbh aus aachen
inzwischen wurde der transporter bauer
von der deutschen post oben übernommen
die jetzt ihre eigenen elektro
transporter baut mit rund 2500
exemplaren auf platz 4 der
meistgenutzten elektroautos in
deutschland und die entwickler sind
bereits am nächsten projekt dran ab 2018
wollen sie ein super günstiges
elektroauto produzieren zum thema
technologiesprung das absolut
alltagstauglich sein soll also trotz der
politik werden sich wohl elektroautos
durchsetzen die dann hoffentlich alle
mit regenerativer energie angetrieben
werden wir halten euch dazu natürlich
wie immer auf dem laufenden wenn er kein
video verpassen wollt dann drückt mir
hier ein aber aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den auf die glocke hier geht es
weiter mit formel bahnbrechende
innovation
da war ich hier beim formel 1 rennen in
berlin absolut irre also unbedingt
anschauen sprich draufklicken ansonsten
bis dann bleibt